[Música]
desde 1929 todos los años se celebra el
4 de octubre el día mundial del animal
el principal objetivo de la fecha es
concientizar sobre los derechos y
protección de los animales y que
coincide además con el día de San
Francisco de Asís Santo patrón y
defensor de los animales saludamos a
Mark lee el ex experto en mascotas y
especialista en adiestramiento escribió
el libro mi sabiduría canina con
editorial al planeta para compartir sus
métodos de convivencia entre humanos y
nuestros animales domésticos Gracias mar
por estar con nosotros esta mañana de
martes en directo América de Francia 24
antes de entrar digamos en nuestra
mascotas Cuál es la importancia de los
animales en nuestro planeta en todos los
ecosistemas
Buenos días Mil gracias por la
invitación y un gusto estar acá con
ustedes en realidad del tema ya va mucho
más allá porque no solamente hacen parte
de la importancia en el ecosistema y en
la evolución de cada uno de ellos sino
la importancia de cómo han venido
socializando y entrando a la vida de los
humanos el animal doméstico hoy en día
hace parte esencial de la vida cotidiana
de los humanos Así que yo creo que esta
tendencia cada vez ha sido mayor y hoy
en día nos preocupa proteger el medio
ambiente precisamente para que este
ecosistema no empiece a sufrir un
impacto tan fuerte hay muchas zonas
donde ya hoy en día la convivencia con
los animales entre ellos mismos sea
complicado mucho Así es marky
lamentablemente también son muchísimos
más las especies de cada día que están
en Vía de extinción o cómo hacer digamos
desde nosotros mismos para proteger a
todos los los animales que están Pues en
Vía de extinción no
la educación es el camino la educación
de los niños el poder estructurar Mentes
nuevas que empiecen a cambiar todo esto
que nos tiramos nosotros durante tantos
años sin habernos dado cuenta nadie nos
enseñó cuando estábamos más pequeños las
consecuencias de todo el daño que
hacíamos en el día a día nadie nos
explicó la importancia de reciclar nadie
nos nos explicó la importancia de
ahorrar agua cuando estábamos pequeños
perdimos por lo menos 4 5 6 décadas en
donde realmente la humanidad se
despreocupó de eso y solamente se
preocupó por las finanzas y el
crecimiento económico a nivel mundial y
Se olvidaron del ecosistema y de los
animales es devastador hoy en día la
deforestación está acabando No solamente
con la posibilidad de el oxígeno y la y
el que tengamos agua sino también De
cuántos animales no pudieron generar su
reproducción en estos ecosistemas y
realmente Pues los perdimos claro marca
hablemos ahora de nuestras mascotas Pero
antes digamos entrar en el tema de sobre
todo lo más comunes los perros y gatos
el daño que le hacemos nosotros también
al al planeta y a los propios animales
de tener estas razas animales exóticos
como como mascotas no muchísimas veces
ilegalmente
Ese es el primer problema que hemos
creído que porque tenemos la capacidad
de económica de comprar de llevarnos a
la casa y de hacer lo que queramos nos
olvidamos de las consecuencias Y de lo
que eso trae después realmente hoy en
día la problemática de los animales
silvestres que se han llevado a los
hogares pues ha sido que como todo lo
ilegal Se ha vuelto un negocio en la
medida en que podamos educar a las
personas vamos a poder hacer que ese
negocio deje de ser un negocio rentable
y se vuelva una crítica de la sociedad
en nuestro país hay carreteras
principales donde si usted vuelve de la
costa al centro del país le están
ofreciendo toda clase de animales
silvestres en las carreteras pero si
educamos a los niños y educamos a los
jóvenes a las consecuencias de esto y
cómo esto impactó tantas décadas después
la problemática seguramente las cosas
van a empezar a cambiar hay muchas
fundaciones y personas de a esto y
realmente creo que hay que apoyarlos Y
darles toda la visibilidad posible para
que sigan haciendo su trabajo marca
Ahora sí hablemos de nuestros perritos y
nuestros gatitos en casa no que no se
beneficia que nos aporta estos
animalitos en nuestro en nuestro día a
día
cuántos tienes tú Yo tengo un perrito
muy bien estás haciendo muy bien la
tarea adoptado Por cierto claro Entonces
ya sabes realmente esos beneficios Mira
yo creo que ya está científicamente
comprobado por múltiples evidencias a lo
largo de tantos años de estudio el tema
de responsabilidad el tema de la
socialización con el entorno la compañía
el la posibilidad de mejorar los estados
de ánimo la posibilidad de mejorar su
condición física de tener unos horarios
un poco más
son múltiples los beneficios que
realmente las mascotas nos traen a
nosotros en los hogares Y yo creo que
cada vez las familias Se han dado cuenta
de esto en mayor proporción y por eso el
crecimiento de la industria en los
últimos 10 o 15 años ha sido tan notable
entremos ahora a un terreno espinoso no
y es la humanización de los animales
estás a estas personas pues que hacen
todo con los animales los tratan como si
fueran sus hijos
esto se puede catalogar como maltrato
animal
absolutamente
absolutamente y ojalá muchos países
pusieran el ojo sobre estas situaciones
y para ponerte un ejemplo sencillo Mira
yo he tenido asesorías que he tenido que
dar a personas que por alguna razón
acuden a mí y perritos pequeños que
nunca han tocado el piso que sus
familias los han llevado alzados y en
coches por toda la vida y tienen un
pañal especial para hacer sus
necesidades dentro de un recinto cerrado
pues ese perro claramente no está
viviendo una buena vida de perro y no
está teniendo un equilibrio con lo que
debería hacer su socialización con el
entorno de los humanos y lo que tiene
que ver con la vida del perro como perro
el perro necesita ser activo necesita
socializar con sus pares necesita tener
un itinerario muy organizado y necesita
entender a su a su día a día hoy en día
la desviación de ese manejo pretendiendo
que el perro viva como nosotros la
pintada de uñas la utilización de
pegamentos para accesorios en su pelaje
nada de eso va acorde a la vida real de
los animalitos es maltrato
Lamentablemente se me acaba el tiempo
para seguir desarrollando este tema no
tan interesante de esta humanización de
las mascotas seguramente más adelante en
otra oportunidad vamos a tener tiempo
para hablar para hablar de ello mar
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo América de Francia 24 un abrazo
un abrazo para todos ustedes y siempre
dispuesto y a la orden para colaborarles
en lo que ustedes quieran es un placer